you have made is this am i correct five
movies now this is the fifth movie that
you're promoting tonight that you've
made with mr simon pegg
yeah you guys have been friends forever
we have yeah and you uh
are great comedically together and uh i
i've seen all the other films and you
guys always do a terrific job you're
very close i saw
a picture of the two of you playing
soccer
and i'd like to know what's happening in
this photo
look at that well that was uh that was
my
honeymoon well that's
it's a very famous photograph we tried
to reenact this photograph now vinnie
jones is obviously a big star here now
he used to be a very hard footballer
very
very tough soccer player and um
he he was playing against this guy
called paul gascoigne who was like the
most amazing soccer player
very silky very skilled and the only way
that he could stop him
uh was during a corner he he
he grabbed his packet and it's a true
story
that's the only way his his defense or
his he was trying against him
was to grab him down there he was to
neutralize him freak his mind out so he
put him off his game
yeah i think it worked it did yeah i
think it worked
so you wanted to recreate that moment
with your friend simon yeah well i mean
we didn't
really one look i mean look at that
football shirt why would i ever say yeah
i'm squeezing to that thing
that was not my idea let me get to this
the world's end uh it's a great idea for
a film
uh a bunch of old friends who had gone
on a legendary pub crawl
20 years earlier decide to get back
together again
and recreate the pub crawl yeah
essentially uh they you know when they
were 18 or 19 the pub crawl failed they
didn't get to the last part but now
we kind of haven't seen each other for
20 years and our leader at the time
gary king played by simon pegg kind of
crops up where we live and where we were
to try and get us back to do
to do this legendary pub crawl and about
you know
30 40 minutes in something happens of
of galactic proportions and it kind of
changes the the course these are the
kind of movies you guys make and it's
what i love about it but yeah there's a
there's a left turn that this film takes
that's that's really fun
uh let's take a look at this clip from
the world's end
we had ourselves a little idea
as you know yeah we're gonna go back to
newton haven why
for some unfinished business
that's a joke right five guys 12 pubs 50
pints
60 pints oh steady on your algae i've
had a drink for 16 years gary
you must be thirsty then but we can go
back see the guys chew the fat it'll be
just like it always was except this time
we are going to finish this thing once
and for all
you have a very selective memory gary
thanks you remember the friday nights
i remember the monday mornings yeah
that's why we're going back on a friday
why do you think none of us live in
newton haven anymore
because it is a black hole it's boring
it always was and it always will be
it's only boring because we're not there
it's pointless arguing with you exactly
so come he's not a good friend
no not at all